[Zene]
köszöntök minden kedves hallgatót a
következő vendége melekes istván akivel
régóta barátok vagyunk és az egyik közös
passziónk az a keresztény vezetés
elmélet ő maga is coachként dolgozik
szervezetfejlesztéssel és vezetőkkel
dolgozik és elkezdünk azokról a témákról
beszélgetni mik igazán provokatívak hogy
mi köze van a kereszténységnek vagy mi
köz lehet a kereszténységnek a
vezetéshez milyen elvek uralják a
keresztény vezetés elméletet és
és egyéb izgalmas témák tartsatok velünk
isti köszöntelek a podcastünkbe igazából
ez egy nagyon izgalmas beszélgetés lesz
nekem mert arról fogunk beszélgetni ami
az egyik hobbim és az egyik kedvenc
témám és az a az érdekes ebbe az egész
beszélgetésbe hogy a hallgatók nem
tudhatják de mi már nagyon régóta
családi barátok vagyunk körülbelül olyan
hat hetente a családunk találkozik és
ilyenkor minden egyes találkozáskor le
tudunk ül és gyakorlatilag pont erről
beszélgetünk ez nem lesz ez a
beszélgetés más mint azok a
beszélgetések annyi különbséggel a
gyerekek nem fognak megszakítani minket
tát a következő másfél órában intenzíven
csak vezetéselméletről és keresztény
vezetéselméletről fogunk beszélgetni de
mielőtt konkrétan belevágnánk magába a
vezetéselmélet bugyraiba szerintem
nagyon érdekes az életutat hogy te mint
aki építő mérnöki szakot végeztél hogy
kerülünk oda hogy mi most vezetés
elméletről beszélgessünk egy kicsit
vezetnéd a hallgatókat abba hogy honnan
indultál és hogy mi az az oka mi az oka
annak hogy most erről beszélgetünk hát
először is szia szavolc és a nézőket
hallgatókat is üdvözlöm
készültem ezzel a dologgal hiszen a az
embernek egyik alapvető tulajdonsága
hogy miérteket keres
ugye azon gondolkozik a a múlt
eseményeiben hogy hogy hogyan fugnek
összeszálak
minden ember narratívákban gondolkozik
ugye mi sokszor szoktunk erről
beszélgetni a találkozásainkor hogy
mennyire komplex a világ és és a
narratívák azért jók hogy
leegyszerűsítenek dolgokat és
elmondhatnám a az egyszerű tényszerű
dolgokat hogy 2008-ban érettségiztem
12-ben
építőmérnökként lediplomáztam majd
dolgoztam a szakmában majd szakmán kívül
majd egy mesterit végeztem el és itt
vagyunk de szeretnék néhány narratívát
ebből fölvázolni az egyik az
ugye realál beállítottságunak gondoltam
magam középiskolába fizika versenyekre
jártam meg matthek versenyekre mathekinó
szakon érettségiztem és elmentem
építőmérnöknek mert hát milyen menő
építeni dolgokat és hát kolozsváron
nagyon élveztem azt a négy évet benne
voltam úgy gondolom a top 10%ban az
egyetemen mint tanulmányi eredmény és és
elkezdtem építő mérnökként dolgozni és
és ráittttem hogy egyre kevésbé izgat ez
a dolog egyre
kevésbé foglalkoztat a szakma és egyre
jobban érdekel hogy azok a cégek vagy
azok a szervezetek ahol dolgozok azok
miért úgy működnek ahogy
működnek nagyon hamar kialakult egy egy
kritikai szemléletem
hogy miérteket tegyek föl
a a főnökeimnek a projektvezetőknek
ezért nem is nagyon
voltam népszerű egy egyes
vállalkozásokban és
és hát hosszú évek alatt vagy néhány év
alatt megérkeztünk oda hogy hogy
rájöttem egy ilyen covidos gondolkodás
el elcsendesedés ideje alatt hogy hogy
mi a közös
a a
szervezetfejlesztésben és a az
építőmérnöki
szakmában vagy miért miért is lehet ez
az én életutam
ban mitért volt szerepe és rájöttem hogy
engem az építőmérnöki szakmában nagyon
foglalkoztatott a rendszer ez a
rendszerszemlélet de a matéria hidegen
hagyott az anyagi
világ és és gondolkoztam hogy mi lehet
az a az a szakma igazából vezetés
elmélettel foglalkozom már lassan 10 éve
amikor inkább csak tanultam olvastam
rengeteg könyvet beszélgettünk
rengeteget egymással képzésekre jártam
és
és hát majdnem teljesen véletlenül
találtam rá a humán erőforrás
menedzsment és szervezet szociológia
szakra amit amit tavaly előtt kezdtem el
és a taval végeztem el a mesteri képzést
ahol megtaláltam ugyanezt hogy rendszer
ha ha csak az emberrel szerettem volna
foglalkozni akkor pszichológus lettem
volna valószínűleg a az
egyéni dolgok az egyéni életutak az
egyéni életpályák foglalkoztat ha
foglalkoztattak volna de engem a
rendszerekér édkeltek az emberek közti
interakciók a szervezetek mi miért mi
úgy működik ahogy a vezetők ha valamit
mondanak az hogyan csapódik le a
a akár egy vállalkozásban egy
szervezetben a a többi tagnak és és ez a
rendszerszemlélet az ami ami
végigvezetett ami egy narratívája ennek
az egész életútnak hogy én ezzel kezdtem
foglalkozni ebbe ástam bele magam é a
keresztényvezetés elmélet lett a a
mesteri disszertációm témája is de akár
egy másik narratívát is tudnék elmondani
hogy egy csodálatos négy évet éltem
kolozsváron egyetemistaként ahol
a kolozsvári egyetemi lelkészségnek
egyik csoportjában voltam tag ugye ott
ismerkedtünk meg és és azt vezettem is
tehát hogy keresztény
vezetőként közösségvezetőként is volt
egy ilyen
belelátásom vagy akár az a harmadik
narratíva hogy az elmúlt 11 éven mer a a
veled való szoros barátságunk hogyan
határozta meg és ebben a az a rengeteg
órányi beszélgetés a vezetéselmélettel
kapcsolatban amit amit megbeszéltünk
úgyhogy három narratívát is hoztam ami
ami a mi értjét igen ez a a
beszélgetésünk mindig egy ilyen
intellektuális birkózás volt egy egy egy
mindig az volt hogy hoztunk egy-egy
gondolatot egy-egy ideát és elkezdtük
húzogatni vizsgálni kitekerni mind a
kettő ben van egy ilyen fajta székely
talán székely humor és és makadság és
talán talán ez is ami összeköt minket
mélyen hogy hogy nem elégszünk meg a
felületes válaszokkal és ezért is akarok
most egy kicsit beszélgetni magáról a
magáról a keresztény vezetésről és úgy
gondoltam hogy közelítsük meg ezt a
kérdést hogy hogy tegyünk fel provokatív
kérdéseket egymásnak kezdjük el egy
kicsit provokálni a másik személyt úgy
ahogy amúgy szoktuk ühüm hogy és ezáltal
bevezetni a hallgatókat abba hogy mit is
értünk mi keresztény vezetés elmélet
alatt és hogy mi a miért gondoljuk azt
hogy hogy ez egy fontos dolog lehet nem
tudom hogy talán még azt azt fontosnak
tartom megemlíteni hogy az elmúlt fél
évben elindítottunk több képzést is és
együtt vettünk részt rajta ebbe a ebbe a
képzésbe az még volt egy harmadik
előadónk is pál fikinga és és nagyon iz
izgalmas tapasztalat volt számomra látni
azt hogy hogyan tudok más nem
informatikus más vezetőkkel hogyan tudok
kapcsolatot létesíteni meg egyáltalán ez
a gondolat az hogy hogy elvek alapján
vezetés ez ez mennyire rezonál a
környezetünkkel úgyhogy az első
provokatív kérdésem most az hogy
szerinted miért kell keresztény legyen
egy vezetés tehát miért nem lehet
egyszerűen ideológiaamentes vagy
vallásmentes egy egy egy vezetés mi
miért kell behozni egyáltalán ezt a szót
hogy
keresztény szinte szinte gondoltam hogy
ez lesz az első kérdésed
és
hát ha nagyon leegyszerűsítjük és akkor
az egyszerűből megyünk a komplex fele
akkor azt gondolom hogy és ezt ezt nem
csak én gondolom ez egy bizonyított tény
hogy az ember az az több dimenziós testi
lelki és és intellektuális dimenziói
vannak és és nem lehet ezeket a
dimenziókat szétválasztani
ö foglalkoztatok már ezekben a
podcastokban az identitásról
ezekről a kérdésekről és én azt mondom
hogy nem kell a vezetés keresztény
legyen
de a keresztény ember keresztényül vezet
mert összefügg a tehát a személyisége az
ugye egy ezt a hármasságot
igazából viszi a testi lelki és és a és
a spirituális dimenzióit és ezek
egymásra hatnak üüm és
és ezért tartom érdekesnek ezeket az
ideológiaamentes
próbálkozásokat amikor azt mondjuk hogy
ezek csak menedzsment eszközök hiszen
úgy ahogy a legelején mondtam minden
narratíva és és a narratíváink
határozzák meg a világunkat az ahogy
látjuk a világot
és és nincs ideológiaamentes világ tehát
az ideológia mentes világ az
gyakorlatilag az objektív valóság lenne
de az objektív valóság annyira komplex
hogy hogy nem lehet narratívák nélkül
tehát egy történet egy történet
leegyszerűsíti a világot számunkra
mindig egy történetben élünk benne ezt
jelenti az igen igen mindig egy
történetben élünk vagy akár úgy is
fogalmazták mindig egy egy paradigmán
keresztül látjuk a a a valóságot mindig
egy egy szemüvegen és az ahogy látunk az
azt ahogy látunk ez a hármasság
határozza meg hogy milyen milyen a a
szellemi képességeink milyenek milyen a
a spirituális
beállítottságunk és és még akár a testi
dimenziónk is meghatározza azt hogy
hogyan látjuk a világot és az hog
ugyanúgy ahogy egy szervezetnek is van
fizikai dimenziója tehát a gazdasági
oldala meg a rendszerei meg tehát
ugyanúgy megvannak mint az embernél ezek
a dimenziók ugyanúgy egy szervezetnél is
megvannak tehát akkor gyakorlatilag
hogyha ha azt mondod hogy hogy képtelen
az ember látni a valóságot egy narratíva
nélkül akkor
gyakorlatilag bármilyen vezetés elmélet
is legyen az valamilyen narratívára épül
abszolút így
gondolom és és hát ezt ezt egyszerű
bizonyítani
gyakorlatilag mondjuk az elmúlt 100 év
amióta ugye az ember vezetés elmélettel
foglalkozik a vezetésudományt mint
tudomány behozta a a kai vezetésből ugye
innen származik nagyjából ez a ez a
vezetéselmélet a a gazdasági
vezetésbe ezért van rengeteg katonai
fogalom amit használnak ugye a
hierarchia mint olyan szintén az
engedelmesség ez mind katonai fogalomból
jött be a a corporate a nagyvállalati
kultúrába ezek mind átitatottak valami
ideológiával és és hát mi még már csak
az utózengését és ugye a a lecsengését
éltük de hogy a a kommunista ideológia
is meghatározott egy kommunista
vezetéselméletet
a hát mondjuk most a a neoliberális vagy
a a posztmodern is meghatároz egy
bizonyos szintű vezetés elméletet van
ahol ahol ezek a a narratívák erősödnek
föl viszont ami nagyon érdekes az az az
hogy hogy úgy gondolom hogy a
kereszténység az úgy kerül ebbe bele
hogy a kereszténység az nem egy
narratíva a sok közül és
és ez
ez a visszaprovokatív kérdés mert ez ez
a beszélgetés így így nagyon érdekes és
én arra is készültem hogy hogy a vezetés
elméletről a keresztényvezetés
elméletről két síkon fogunk beszélgetni
vagy beszélgessünk hiszen
én nem vezetek vállalkozást
nem nincsen csapatom
mondjuk úgy hogy ilyen idézőjeles
szakértői mivoltomba tudok ebben
nyilatkozni meg az a sok elmélet amit
végigvettem viszont te itt vagy és van
neked tapasztalati
tárad és egy empirikus meghatározást is
tudsz ennek adni és és erről már sokat
beszéltünk hogy hogy az ideológiák azok
nem verséyeznek egymással hanem van a az
alapelveken nyugvó és az a kérdésem hogy
szerinted miért nem
miért nem vagy vagy így gondolod-e hogy
a az ideológiák között nincs egyenlőség
és nem nem versen nznek ezek egymással
igen tehát e gyakorlatilag a ez egy
nagyon fontos kérdés hogy a
kereszténység az egy változata a többi
vezetés elméletnek vagy a vezetés
elmélet amivel érdemes foglalkozni és
egyetértek ezzel eddig
hogy hogy nincs ideológiaamentes vezet
tehát valami mozgatja valamilyen szándék
valamilyen vezérel valamilyen mintázat
minden egyes szervezet működését és
kérdés az hogy mi az ami mozgatja mert
hogyha nem beszélünk róla attól még
mindig mozgatja tehát a háttérben van
valami ami irányítja a figyelmet az
erőforrásokat és a döntéseket ha egy
kapitalista mondhatná valaki azt hogy
engem most nem érdekel ez a sok minden
én akarom intézni a dolgaimat azért hogy
hogy pénzt keressek de hogyha elkezdjük
kérdezni miért akarsz pénzt keresni meg
hogyan akarod az embereket motiválni meg
hogyan akarjuk a hogyan akarjuk a hogyan
készülünk fel a jövőre egyáltalán mit
gondolunk a jövőről mit gondolunk az
ember szerepéről tehát amikor elkezdünk
ilyen kérdéseket feltenni akkor vagy az
van hogy nem válaszolunk rá és úgy
próbálunk
ideológiaamentesek lenni hogy nincsenek
válaszaink vagy pedig elkezdünk
gondolkozni rajta é akkor már ezek már
filozófiai kérdésekké válnak mi az ember
szerepe a világban és mi is az ember
szerepe a világban ez egy nagyon fontos
kérdés és azt látom főleg
informatikusként hogy ez engem hamarabb
ért ez a kérdés talán mint a többi
szakmabeli
többi embert aki elkezdett dolgozni ezel
öttem hát most már 10 éve mindjárt 20
éve mert az informatikusok sokat
keresnek és a azáltal hogy hogy nagy a
fizetésük azáltal hamarabb jutnak el
ahhoz a kérdéshez hogy oké akkor miért
dolgozom mert az aki napi az aki
kevesebbet keres és az a célja hogy
többet keressen addig gyakorlatilag
elfedődik ez a kérdés gyakorlatilag
maximalizálni akarja a fizetését
szüksége azért akar többet dolgozni vag
é nagyobb fizetést szerezni hogy és
akkor ak kiegészíti a saját
életcéljaival de amikor már ez
megtörténik egy informatikus esetében
akkor már sokkal hamarabb elkerül ahhoz
a kérdéshez hogy miért miért dolgozok mi
minek van értelme és akkor ha ezt a
miértet felteszi
valaki körülbelül a 30-as éveire
közepére az emberek eljutnak ehhez a
kérdéshez így vagy úgy mert mert
történik egy váltás tehát ez a a
felnőtté válásnak a a a része amikor már
az a kezdeti eufória eltűnik hogy hogy
már dolgozok és van fizetésem és
utazhatok és ezt megtehetem és azt
megtehetem és akkor feltevődik a kérdés
rendben e az egész miért van és akkor ez
ez ez egy nagyon
nehéz nagyon nehéz helyzet ez egy krízis
helyzet az ember életében és azt hiszem
hogy hogy részben ezért is van hogy a
szientológia ennyire terjedhet a
környezetünkben mert erre egy
alternatíva a miértre egy alternatíva de
ugyanúgy válasz erre a miértre a
keresztény vezeté t és akkor
visszatérünk az eredeti kérdéshez hogy
hogy az a a a a keresztény válasz az
mennyivel hatékonyabb válasz a miértre
mint bármilyen más válasz és ez itt
valójában akkor dől el amikor az ember
elkezdi praktikusan ezt élni tehát a a a
kereszténység számomra egy nagyon
praktikus vallás nem lehet elméletben
tehát elméletben sok mindent lehet
beszélni de amikor konkrétan elkezdünk
cselekedni és megnézni a
cselekedeteinknek a gyümölcsét abban a
pillan patban kiderül hogy milyen elvek
azok amik mozgatják a világot és én
ilyen elveket nagyon sokat kaptam
amielyekre rájöttem hogy legmélyebben
keresztény n elvek most csak egyet
mondok a hallgatóknak de szerintem a
következő másfél óra ezzel fog telni
hogy folyamatosan beszélgettünk
mindenféle
elvekről de számomra egy nagyon
megdöbbentő felismerés volt az hogy a
pszichológiának minden egyes iskolája
függetlenül attól hogy hogy most rogery
vagy j vagy vagy frajdi minden egyes
iskolája rájött egy alapelvre mégpedig
az hogy ha valaki
önként szembeszáll a félelmével annak
gyógyító hatása van tegyük fel félünk a
magasságoktól az egyik módszer arra hogy
hogy ezt le tudjuk küzdeni az az hogy a
problémát megfogjuk és lekicsinyítjük
annyira kicsivé
hogy hogy hogy meg lehessen ezt ugrani
ezt a lépést tegyük fel valaki fél a
lifttől a bezártságtól hogy b a liftbe
akkor az első lépés az hogy
egyáltalán be oda tudsz-e menni egy
lifthez azt mondja a másik nem jó akkor
akkor itt van egy kép egy liftről rá
tudnál-e nézni a liftajtóra azt mondja
hogy nem akkor lépjünk még egy lépést
vissza
akkor próbáld meg a fejedben felidézni
azt a képet amelyik a liftajtóról szó
fel tudnád-e idézni és akkor azt mondja
tegyük fel hogy ezt most még meg tudnám
csinálni jó akkor idézzük fel rendben
akkor felidéztük a következő alkalommal
akkor meg tud tudnák-e nézni ezt a képet
hát már már meg tudjuk nézni a következő
alkalommal akkor oda tudnánk-e menni egy
liftajtóhoz hát az még nem akkor a
kinttről az ajtó tehát hogy a a a
távolról nézni a liftajtót megtudni azt
megtudjuk és akkor így fokozatosan
közelebb megyünk a lifthez utána meg
mernék-e nyomni egy gombot igen akkor
utána be mernék-e úgy menni hogy utána
egyből ki is szállok a liftből és akkor
utána bemegyek és akkor ott maradok egy
pár másodpercet és és akkor megmerném-e
úgy nyomni azt a gombot hogy egy
emelettel megyek fennebb és lassan
lassan az emberek így képesek
szembeszállni ezzel az absztrakt
sárkánnyal a fejükbe azért mer azért
absztrakt mert bár konkrétnak tűnik de
abban a pillanatban mihelyt a liftel
elkezdenek tudni élni és használni mint
eszköz abban a pillanatban egy absztrakt
feladatot egy absztrakt félelmet győztek
le a fejükbe és az életük több területén
megjelenik egy pozitív változás tehát ez
ez ebben egyetért minden pszichológiai
iskola és valójában az elv mögötte az
hogy ha önként vállaljuk a
szenvedésünket ha önként vállaljuk azt a
fájdalmat ami amin keresztül kell
menjünk nem pedig az áldozataivá válunk
abban a pillanatban ennek megváltóereje
van ez a legmélyebb gondolat a
legmélyebb keresztény gondolat ez egy ez
egy hihetetlen gondolat mert mert
valójában ez a kérdés hogy most egy
szervezet melyik szervezet működik
jobban az amelyik képes arra hogy önként
szembeszálljon a félelmeivel a
változékony piaci realitásokkal a a a
belső konfliktusokkal vagy az amelyik
megpróbálja ezeket elpalástolni és
egyértelmű hogy az amelyik önkénteszi az
sokkal de sokkal hatékonyabb mint az
amelyik amelyik nem önkénteszi úgyhogy
ez a mondjam úgyha rövid válaszom arra
hogy miért tehát ez ez például egy mély
keresztényelv a legmélyebb keresztényelv
az önként vállalt szenvedésnek a
megváltó hatása ez a krisztusi kép
amelyik a kereszten önként vállalta a a
halált úgyhogy úgyhogy úgyhogy igen
számomra a keresztény vezetés elmélet az
egy e az egy valami olyan ami ami
kimagas a többi vezetés elmélettel
szemben ugyanis emberekkel dolgozunk és
ugyanúgy érvényes ez az önként vállalt
szenvedés minden egyes emberre nem csak
ránk hanem az egész szervezeten
végigvanul így fraktálszerűen
megismétlődik mintaszerűen és és és
áthatja az egész kultúránkat és és az
embernek szüksége van arra hogy ne csak
dolgozzon és éljen napról napra hanem
valami értelmes legyen az amit csinál
valami nagyobbnak legyen a része az amit
csinál és kérdés az hogy mi minek a
része ezek már olyan kérdések amik már a
miért elkötődn miért élünk a földön mi
mi értelme van enni mi értelme van
dolgozni egyáltalán van-e értelme
például gyermeket szülni erre a világra
ez ez is egy fontos kérdés és van erre
egy keresztény válasz és van erre egy
nem keresztény válasz é én azt látom a
keresztény válasz az amivel ha valaki
kapitalista módon önző módon azt
szeretné hogy a cége jobban működjön
akkor is érdemes a keresztény
gondolatokhoz hozzá nyúlni de én mondjuk
nem ezen a szinten szeretem élni a
keresztényvezetés elméletet ahol ahol
dönzőkapitalista módon használjuk mint
egy automata ezeket az elveket hanem
hanem az ahol egy élőkapcsolatunk van
istennel és imádkozunk folyamatosan
úgyhogy ez a rövid válaszom a a a ezzel
kapcsolatban nem tudom te is
hozzáfűzhetsz hog neked mi a véleményed
valami még megpengetődött-e benned
ezáltal így
ami hát igazából azt azt látom és
két két itt itt érdemes egyből
különbséget tenni a a keresztény vállalk
ás vagy a keresztény vezetés és a és a
vallásos
ság között
és ez egy ez egy újabb dimenzió
keresztény vezetőnek lenni
a akár a kutatásaimból ugye tizen 11
néhány vállalkozóval készítettem m
interjút a mesteri disszertációmhoz és
és azt az az egyik megállapítás hogy a a
a ker
vállalkozó a kereszténységét a
vezetésben nem a nem
a keresztény menedzsment eszközökkel ha
létezik ilyen hogy megkeresztelt
menedzsment eszközökkel érje el
hanem hanem ezek a vállalkozók nem
tartják magukat a legfelsőbb szintű
vezetőnek mindannyian úgy gondolják hogy
hogy őket vezeti valaki és és szerintem
a a többi ideológiái ideológiai vezetés
és a keresztény vezetés között ez az
egyik legnagyobb különbség hogy maga a
szolgálat és az hogy vezetve vagyok itt
jelenik meg egyedül és itt jelenik meg a
legerőteljesebben hogy a keresztény
vezető az elsősorban attól keresztény
mint minden más keresztény ember hogy
élő kapcsolata van az istennel és és ez
az élő kapcsolat ez odav visszaműködik
és és van egy vezetettség benne és van
egy alázat hogy nem én vagyok a főnök
hanem hanem én a végrehajtó vagyok én
vagyok a földi végrehajtója annak a
vezetőnek aki aki ezt az egészet
eltervezte és vezeti és és azt látom
hogy beszéltem olyan vállalkozókkal akik
úgy fogalmaztak hogy ők már vállalkozók
voltak és vezetők több több 10 vagy akár
100 tagú vállalkozást tehát
munkással létező vál zást vezettek a
megtérésükkor és azt mondták hogy hogy
nem 180 fokot
de ki se tudják fejezni hogy a megtérés
előtt és a megtérés után mekkorát
változott a akár a vezetéssel
kapcsolatos szemléletük a
vállalkozásukban és és azt gondolom hogy
ez a ez a
különbség hogy az ideológiák nagy része
az mondjuk úgy hogy ilyen ember által
barkácsolt és az ember van a csúcsán
a kereszténységnek a
csúcsán a golgotáján ott van az a az a
krisztusi megváltómű amiről az előbb
beszéltél az önként vállalt szenvedés de
ott van a szolgálat és én a ezt az
alapelvet emelném ki igazából a a
vezetőnek a szolgálata
hogy aki első akar lenni közületek az
legyen az utolsó és aki aki a
a a főhelyekre akar ülni az üljön üljön
hátrébb és vegyen vissza az arcából én
ezt így fordítanám le magamnak
és az hogy hogy krisztus megmossa a
lábait a
tanítványainak amikor ezt a szintű
alázatot és ezt a szintű szolgálatot
látod egy
vállalkozásba ennek megrendítő ereje van
akár így külső szemmel akár
vállalkozásban dolgozó alkalmazottként
vagy akár egy egy random szervezet tehát
hogy hogy nem csak vállalkozások vannak
szervezetek szervezetként működik az
egyház szervezetként működnek civil
szervezetek akár csoportok de amikor a a
vezető rájön hogy neki az elsődleges
feladata a vállalkozásában a
szervezetben az hogy szolgáljon
ennek életeket formáló hatása van és
és ez a típusú ilyen transzformációs
vezető vagy vezetés azt hiszem ez a ez a
legerősebb
ö számomra a legerősebb pontja a a
keresztényvezetés elméletnek mert a
többi gyakorlatilag az menedzsment
eszköz és és kipróbált menedzsment akár
évszázadok óta kipróbált menedzsment
eszközök vannak van ami működik van ami
nem működik
és ugye ez volt az egyik kritika a
tanáraim részéről a a disszertációval
kapcsolatban is hogy leírtam nagyon sok
menedzsment eszközt benne és az volt a
kérdés de ez ezek ezek menedzsment
eszközök ühüm
és igen a a vezetés az menedzsment
eszközöket
használ viszont a a menedzsment eszközök
kiválasztása annak a használata és az
hogy miért miért azt és miért úgy ez ez
azt hiszem ez a kereszténysége
egy keresztény vezet sőt én azt is
tudnám mondani hogy egy hatékony
menedzsment eszköznek az alapjaiban ott
van ott vannak keresztény gondolatok
tehát a egy evaluálási rendszert hogyha
most létrehozunk az hogy miért úgy néz
ki ez az evaluálási rendszer meg hogy mi
is a szerepe pontosan meg hogyan fog ez
manifesztálódni amikor egy csapatban
elkezdjük ezt alkalmazni ez ez ennek a
sikere szerintem attól függ hogy
mennyire mély archetipikus elvekre épül
az az az a rendszer emlékszem hogy az
egyik csapatba bevezettünk egy egy
evaluálási rendszert és egy hihetetlen
félelem fogta el az embereket mert ez az
evaluálási rendszer egy 360 fokos
evaluálási rendszer ahol mindenki
mindenkit evaluál van benne egy
nyitottság van benne egy egy
transzparencia és félnek az emberek
transzparensek lenni félnek attól hogy
kritikát fogalmazzanak meg vagy hogy
kritikát fognak megfogalmazni velük
szembe
és és ez nagyon rosszul is elsülhetett
volna és gyanítom hogyha rossz elvekre
épül ez az evaluál rendszer akkor
tényleg katasztrofálisan sül el annyira
katasztrofálisan lehet egy botrány ki
robban onnan abból a csapatból lehet
hogy lehet hogy következményei lettek
volna de nem ez történt tehát
rizikóztattunk de valahol az volt az
érzésem és ez is egy még keresztény el
hogy ha alapelvek szerint kezdek
építkezni abban a pillanatban ami fog
történni az jó lesz és ez számomra
nagyon megnyugtató így beszéltél erről
hogy
hogy hogy egy vezető számára nagyon
stresszes vezetni mert a végtelen
káoszban kell valahol utat találni
magunknak és és emberek vagyunk és jó
hogyha alázatosak vagyunk mert nem
tudjuk kiszámolni a jövőt nekem sok
biztonságot okoz az hogy vannak
alapelvek vannak alapelvek amire lehet
építeni és hogyha ezeket az alapelveket
megértjük és egyre tisztábban
megfogalmazzuk akkor elkezdjük tudni
ezeket beépíteni és amibe beépítjük a az
alapelveket az elkezd tudni funkcionálni
úgy ahogy ez az evaluálási rendszer
hihetetlen sikere lett ennek az
evaluálási rendszer nek amúgy megsukom
és és alig várom hogy már a következő
évben még egyet evaluáljunk és igen
szóval a menedzsment eszközöknél is én
én az én kritikám az lenne most így amit
a tanáraidnak tudnék mondani hogy az
eszközök nem az éterben vannak hanem
ahhoz hogy működjenek embereken kell
működjön és az ember valamilyen
valamilyennek van teremtve vagy
valamilyen az ember úgyhogy úgyhogy igen
de most azt hiszem az én sorom jön egy
provokatív kérdésfeltevésébe úgyogy pont
reflektálni akartam erre a
szolgálóvezető ami megint egy egy
keresztény elv a szolgálóvezetőnek a a a
stílusára hogy egyáltalán ez ez ez
működhet tehát hogy egy vadkapitalista
környezetben ahol határidőre kell
teljesíteni és mindenféle furcsa figurák
megfordulnak működhet a szolgálóvezető
a szolgálóvezetői
attitűd két kétféle kritikát kaptam már
a szolgálóvezetővel kapcsolatban az
egyik egy kicsit finomabb a másik meg
meg azt hiszem hogy hogy ez az a
formátum ahol ezt ki lehet mondani azt
mondták hogy a szolgálóvezető vagy ugy
amúgy a keresztény vezető az egy ilyen
mondom akkor a durvábbat ilyen jó
indulatú a a más ezt kisipójuk
nem biztos hogy ki kell sípolni a másik
meg meg egyszerűen az hogy hogy hát ezek
ilyen humanisták ühm
emlékszem édesapám azt mondta hogyha
ezekkel az elvekkel elkezdek vezetni
akkor csak idő kérdése lesz hogy mikor
fognak engem otthagyni a amikor kicsit
össze elszedték magukat a munkatársaim
akkor lelépnek majd kábé ez volt a a
jóslata édesapámnak nem minth hogyha ezt
szerette volna de meg akart óvni attól a
keserűségtől meg csalódástól ami ért
volna potenciálisan de igen szóval
szerinted ez akkor akkor mi az ami miatt
nem válunk jó indulatú balfaszokká
és ez ez a másik dimenziója a a szolgáló
vezetésnek és ezt is istentől tanuljuk
és látjuk hogy hogy a szolg áó vezető az
a az az egyik arca a keresztény
vezetőnek a másik arca az az meg a a a
harcos vezető és
és erről is már beszélgettünk hogy isten
országában nincs
demokrácia ott ott vezetett autonómia
van ott nem kérdezi meg
isten a véleményedet hanem elmondja hogy
mi az ő akarata de mégis
mégis ő szolgál krisztuson keresztül
felénk azzal hogy adja a megváltást és
és ez a a a szolgáló vezetés az
gyakorlatilag
úgy nyilvánulhat meg
hogy a a
vezető nek az egyik feladata az hogy
hogy folyamatosan az erőforrásokat de ez
nem csak fizikai hanem mindenféle
erőforrást biztosítson a csapatának és
ezért nem hagyják ott szerintem vagy nem
hagytak ott téged a miután megerősödtek
a vállalkozásban a a
beosztottak mert olyan szintű
erőforrásokat biztosítasz keresztény
vezetőként nekik a szolgálatod által ami
amit máshol nem kapnának meg és ezt
belátja minden ember és it megint arra
térnék vissza hogy hogy megrendítő
hatása van egy lábmosás nak és ez most
egy idézőjeles lábmosás de az amikor a
vállalkozó
egy egy vezető
a az első nagy profitból nem egy egy
x5-öst vagy egy mit tudom ennél jobb
autót is tudnék kitalálni de hát elég
gyakori a székely székelyföldi
vállalközö között az x5-ös tehát hogy
nem egy x5-öst vesz
hanem hanem mondjuk megköszöni és
és létrehoz egy
részesedési rendszert a vállalkozásában
ez ezek megrendítő hatásóak
és és ez az ami ami megtartja
és itt itt megint a a fundamentumához
tudunk visszajüni hogy hogy krisztus
volt az első szolgáló vezető
azt várták tőle hogy ő majd most a román
kifejezés jütt nekem eszembe ez a tjesi
szonzura tehát hogy aztán megold mindent
és elrendez mindent és és mégis
hát azzal a azzal az alázatával is
szolgálatával hát 2000 éves nyomot
hagyott itt a földön
és lehet hogy a vállalkozás indulásakor
nem vagy az első első szakaszban nem a
gazdasági növekedés lesz egy ilyen
vállalkozáson belül viszont az hogy
humán erőforrás szempont ból egy baromi
stabil dolgot lehet ezzel összehozni az
100% sőt én még azt is hozzátenném hogy
szerintem gazdasági szempontból is jobb
eredményeket ér el egy keresztény egy
igazán keresztény vezetésen alapuló cég
mint egy nem keresztény vezetésen
alapuló cég egész egyszerűen azért mert
ahol a bizalom magas egy szervezeten
belül ott minden gyorsabb és minden
olcsóbb és sokkal versenyképesebb lesz
egy olyan cég ahol nem kell folyamatosan
a vezető minden egyes cselekedetét nézze
a a munkatársainak és nem kell
mikromenedseljen mert az emberek
önmagukat vezetik és
önmaguk döntenek úgy hogy szembeszállnak
azzal a a a fájdalommal szenvedéssel ami
ami éppen adatott nekik és egy alázat
van ami ami ami együtt jár egy
keresztény
világképpel sokszor gondolkozok ezen
hogyha most a a cégünket copypastelnék
tehát kimásolnák és a a az út túloldalán
lenne egy pont ugyanolyan cég pont
ugyanolyan kliensekkel pont ugyanolyan
lehetőségekkel de nem keresztény
elméletten működne hanem hanem a
saját vagy más elméleten alapulna akkor
egyszerűen esélyük nem lenne egy idő
után lemaradnának és egészen egyszer
egyszerűen azért mert hányszor kerülünk
oda szinte hetente vagy vagy havonta
amikor pont ez a belső alázat ez az
önként vállalt szenvedésgondolata a
nyertesnyertes mentalitás a bőségment
itás a a proaktivitás ezek a gondolatok
azok amik egy lépéssel előbbre visznek
minket és amikor megbízhatok a
munkatársaimban miközben ez a podcast
folyik most éppen az a forgatás folyik
eszembe nem jut hogy a munkatársaim
dolgoznak-e biztos vagyok benne hogy
hogy mindegyikük dolgozik amiatt mert
nem én motiválom őket pénzzel hanem
belülről van motiválva ez a szervezet
egy vízióval és ezt a víziót egy
alárendeltük istennek ezt tudom mondani
de ez ez hogy mit jelent konkrétan ez ez
egy komplexebb kérdés
te te sorod jön azt hiszem mivel
provokálnál engem
igen hát szerintem az egyik nagy
kihívása és ezt a ezt a kérdést én is
megkaptam hogy hogy akkor a keresztény
vállalkozó vállalkozásában csak
keresztények
dolgozhatnak és és mi történik hogyha
hogyha valaki más ideológiai háttérrel
jön vagy egyszerűen csak úgy gondolja
hogy ez ezt kint kell hagyni a cégen
kívül h
igen hát a az én válaszom erre az hogy
egyértelműen nem tehát hogy hogy
alkalmazunk a cégünkhöz nem keresztény
elvek alapján élő személyeket is
pontosabban akik nem tehát nem kell egy
ilyen ilyen hiszek egyet felmondani a az
állásinterjúna és nem kell egyetértsen
velünk mindenben viszont alázatos kell
legyen ami egy keresztény érték alázatos
kell legyen hogy minden nem tudhat és
hogy hogy ne akarjon azzal az
arroganciával bejönni hogy ő majd
megreformálja a cégünket mert mi el
vagyunk tévedve hanem figyeljen tanuljon
mert van mit tanulnia és és egyszer
nézzen körbe mielőtt meg akar
változtatni egy
rendszert nem árt az sem
hogyha ha proaktív hogyha nem gondolja
magát áldozatnak amúgy ez egy keresztény
gondolat hogy nem vagyunk tehát nyilván
hogy egy csomó minden ér minket de nem
nem vagyunk kiszolgáltatva hanem képesek
vagyunk az áldozatot önként felvállalni
tehát a proaktivitás abszolút egy egy
alapelv és ezt nézzük hogy mennyire
alázatos és mennyire proaktív valaki egy
interjún mert annyira nekünk nem annyira
fontos a
a a teljesítménye a szakmai tudása mint
a jelleme tehát hogyha kell a kettő
közül választani akkor én inkább a
jellemet választom mert sokkal nehezebb
egy olyan embert találni akinek a
jelleme a helyén van mint az aki
kompetens kompetens embereket fogunk
találni de kompetens arrogáns embereket
biztos hogy ha elkezdek tömöríteni a
cégbe az az az valahol katasztrófához
fog vezetni széthúzáshoz viszont hogyha
alázatos embereket akik képesek tanulni
proaktívan és önként vállalt
szenvedéssel nekivágni a a az útjának az
életének hihetetlen életutakat láttam
tehát a munkatársaim egyikünk se zseni
tehát nem szupersztárokból áll a
csapatunk és mégis egy kivételes
teljesítményt nyújt a csapatunk
összességében és ez a szép benne hogy
hogy az ember aki alázatosan
folyamatosan fejlődik egyszerűen
gyönyörű hetetlen hogy mit tud egy ember
elérni akkor hogyha ha elkezd fejlődni
úgyhogy visszatérve nem nem
keresztényeket alkalmazunk nem is egy
kritérium hogy valaki hívő legyen az egy
az viszont egy kritérium hogy ne
kritizálja a kereszténységet ész nélkül
tehát hogy én szívesen vitatkozok amúgy
az emberekkel és és szívesen hallgatok
meg provokatív dolgokat de a kellő
alázat szükséges ahhoz hogy hogy hogy
egyáltalán tudjunk együtt dolgozni ne
feltételezze hogy tud mindent hanem
hanem beszélgessünk és én feltételezem
azt hogy én sem tudok mindent hanem
hanem fogok tudni majd tanulni attól a
személytől úgyhogy igen a válasz ez hogy
nem csak keresztények jöhetnek a a
szervezetünkbe akkor ennél egy
provokatívabb kérdés talán az hogy mi
van hogyha egy olyan személy jön aki
eleve nem ért egyet a kereszténységgel
vagy vagy azt gondolja hogy hogy ez így
nem működhet vagy vagy hogy nem is fog
működni a hát eleve már akkor benne van
a válaszban az is hogy alig várja hogy
bebizonyítsa hogy ez nem működik és az
nem egy hatékony módszer hogy valaki aki
azt nézi hogy mikor fog elbukni és azt
mondja hhá én megmondtam nem így kell
működjön egy szervezet hanem én tudom
hogy hogy kell hát akkor akkor kész
alapítson egy másik céget sok sikert
kívánok
igen nem tudom hogy ez van-e valami
gondolatod nyugodtan deehát ez egy
beszélgetés nemem nem csak így
dobálozunk a kérdésekkel
igen
ö nincs itt igazából már egy egy újabb
újabb gondolat ugrott be és ez ez
szintén ez a a az előző kérdéshez hogy
hogy működhet-e egy keresztény
működhet-e a keresztény vezetés a
kapitalista világba és és nagyon érdekes
gondolat volt ez a ugye a bibliai
gondolat hogy méltó a munkás a maga
bérére és a és ez a méltányos bérezés és
itt is
többször többször beszélgettünk
a a kutatásban is a vállalk
vállalkozókkal hogy ők ők méltányosnak
gondolják-e a fizetést és a munkások
méltányosnak
gondolják-e és azt gondolom hogy itt nem
is az a fontos hogy méltányosabb érezés
egy
keresztény által vezetett vállalkozásban
hiszen nagyon nehéz objektíven a
méltányosságot mérni tehát meg lehet
próbálkozni és azt mondani hogy akkor mi
a vásárlói erő székelyudvarhelyen mik az
átlagbérek
mi az a fogyasztói kosár amit úgy
általában átlagosan használ fogyasztanak
az emberek
hány százalékal nagyobb vagy kisebb a
fogyasztói
milyen a fogyasztói magatartás tehát
hogy szektoron belüli átlagfizetés
mindenfélét össze lehet számolni és
akkor azt mondani hogy haa te farizeus
voltál azt mondtad hogy méltányosak a
bérek de 13%-kal kisebb béreket adsz
mint nem tudom mi
de az a gondolat hogy egy egy ember
elgondolkozik azon hogy én vajon
méltányos fizetést adok-e
már ez mélyen keresztény szerintem és
mélyen szintén ennek is ennek is
átformáló hatása van és amikor tovább
megy és megkérdezi a az alkalmazottaktól
a csapattól hogy hogy szerintetek
méltányos-e az a fizetés és akkor erről
lehet beszélgetni lehet
beszélgetni ezekről a dolgokról ez ha
nem
is keresztényi de de egy valami olyan
extrémum itt székelyföldön amivel
nehezen nem találkozok máshol csak
keresztény vállalkozásoknál és tudom
hogy hogy nálatok ez
mondjam azt hogy ez egy ilyen
különlegesség az exárnál és
ennek a a spirituális oldaláról hogyha
mesélnél hogy milyen hatással volt a
nyitott fizetési rendszer és az hogy
hogy méltányos béreket adtok hm a ha
tetszik ez az epizód akkor kérlek
iratkozz fel a csatornánkra vagy írd meg
kommentbe hogy milyen más témáról
hallanál még szívesen azt hittem most az
én sorom jön egy provokatív kérdésbe de
már egy kicsit el vagyok ebbe bel
belekeveredtem igen
szóval azt látom isten országa egy
fejjel lefele fordított világ ahol az
utolsóból lesznek az elsők és ott akik a
az életüket meg akarják tartani azok el
kell veszítsék és fordítva akik élni
akarnak azok akik igen akik élni akarnak
először is meg kell halljanak rengeteg
fej lefele fordított el van és ez ez
ezek meghökkentőek tehát szembem mennek
a azokkal a trendekkel amiket most
látunk és például a nyitott fizetési
rendszer az egy ilyen trend volt nálunk
ami
ami ami meghökkenti az embereket de úgy
elgondolkodtatja őket hogy ez ez hogyan
lehetséges hogy mit azt jelenti a
nyitott fizetési rendszer a hallgatók
kedvére hogy nálunk mindenki tudja
mindenkinek a fizetését és van egy
képlet ami alapján ki lehet számolni
tehát már nem egymással versenyzünk
hanem saját magunkkal versenyzünk és
tudja mindenki hogy ha azt akarja hogy
növekedjen a fizetés akkor mit kell
csináljon és a feladatunk ilyenkor már
nem az hogy tehát legalábbis nekem én
vezetőnek hogy kialkudozzam a minimális
fizetést neki amivel tudom maximalizálni
a profitot hanem hanem az hogy hogyan
tudjuk optimalizálni az ő fizetését és
ez egy közös alkú tárgya hogy mit jelent
az optimum tehát hogy mit jelent hogy
optimális fizetés
úgyhogy de ehhez hasonló rendszerünk sok
van ami szembemegy így a a a kapitalista
elvekkel és azt gondolhatná az ember
első hallásra hogy ez nem működhet nem
működhet mert előbb-utóbb vissza fognak
élni vele például az evaluálási rendszer
egy ilyen hogy egymást evaluáljuk és a
fizetésünknek a
a mértéke az befolyásolva van az
evaluálás által engem is evaluálnak a
munkatársaim vagy tizenvalamennyi való
állást kapok fél évente és az én
fizetésem is az alapján alakul hogy hogy
mit mondanak nekem a munkatársaim és
pontosan emiatt történik meg az hogy
nagyon hitelessé válik a dolog tehát még
az elején lehet egy egy manipulatív
trüknek gondolni ezt az evaluálási
rendszert vagy a fizetési rendszert de
abban a pillanatban mit az én saját
fizetésem is látják a munkatársaim hogy
hogy nem is én kezelem amúgy a pénzt
úgyhogy nem is én osztom ki ilyen
szempontból a saját magamnak a fizetést
de látják a munkatársaim hogy mekkora a
fizetésem és le is szavazhatnak és meg
is történt ez még jó pár évvel ezelőtt
hogy egy olyan időszakban voltunk ahol
stresszesebb voltam és türelmetlenebb
voltam és pont az egyik munkatársam rám
szólt czevalóállásba sőt két munkatársam
is leszavazott látszott hogy a görbébe a
fizetésem lecsökkent abb a fél évbe mert
türelmetlen voltam és azt mondták hogy
oké ha már ezekről az elvekről beszélsz
akkor akkor legyél számon kérve a saját
elveid alapján úgyhogy emiatt válik egy
nagyon hiteles valamivé és ez ez ez
folyamatosan éberen is kell hogy tartson
mert abban a pillanatban amiv itt
elalzik a figyelmem abban a pillanatban
egyből szólnak a munkatársaim jó
indulattal kedvesen de szólnak hogy
figyelj ez így nem lesz jó mert ha ezt
így folytatod tovább akkor akkor például
baj lesz tegyük fel kiégettem magam vagy
már kezd hiteltelenné válni úgyhogy
úgyhogy ez a fajta
út a ez a ez ez a fajta keresztény út ez
ez ez ez ez egy mély mély bizalmat hoz a
szervezetünkbe még mindig mondhatná
valaki amúgy hogy hogy ez ez oké de ezek
menedzsment eszközök tehát nem nem
keresztény olyan értelemben hogy nincs
benne élő dolog hanem hanem keresztény
elvekre húztunk rá managzsment
eszközöket és és akkor oké ezek jól
működnek oké elfogadjuk hogy jól működik
de mitől válik ez élővés azt hiszem hogy
a kérdésed pont erre vonatkozott most a
legutoljára hogy hogy mi az ami
megkülönböztet minket mint keresztény
cég hogy esetleg meg tudnád-e ismételni
pontosan de azt hiszem hogy erre
értetted e ezt a kérdést hogy a az élő
részére hogyan tud működni ez az élő
része nem nem fogom tudni megismételni a
kér
dst viszont akkor át átforgatom egy
picit és és akkor beszélgethetünk arról
most egy picit szerintem hogy hogy igen
ezek menedzsment eszközök
és a kereszténység az az az nem nem az
alapelvek egymás után tétele vagy nem a
az eszközöknek a a a kiválasztása hanem
az az a legelején már ugye beszéltünk
erről hanem az egy élők kapcsolat a az
istennel és
és az hogy
ez ez a kapcsolat nyilvánul meg a vezető
életében ez az ami ami szerintem
meghatározza azt
hogy hogy keresztény elveket
alkalmazó vezető lesz vagy keresztény
vezető lesz és ez az integritásban
látszik és erről beszéltél most az előbb
egy rövidet hogy hogy az emberek azok
folyamatosan mérnek mindenkit mérnek és
és a legkisebb hiteltelenségre is egyből
reagálnak abszolút és és sajnos azt a
kultúrát éljük akár itt székföldön de
szerintem ezt ezt globálisan is egy
picit így van hogy mérnek
ítélnek és nem adnak visszajelzést nincs
lehetőség
korrigálni és
egy olyan k
kultúrában és ez ez egy keresztény
vezetőnek például az egyik egyik fontos
feladata hogy olyan kultúrát létrehozni
ahol van lehetőség visszajelezni és pont
a a mai evangéliumot
olvastam és ugye az a a példabeszéd a
szákáról és a gerendáról hogy hogy
meglátod a másik szemében a a a szákát
de a sajátodban nem látod meg a
gerendát a vál ozó vagy a vezetőnek az
integritása az ezen a két dolgon múlik
hogy hogy meglátja-e a saját szemében a
gerendát hogy folyamatosan építi a
hitelességét és épít egy olyan kultúrát
ahol mégis bizalommal vissza lehet
jelezni akár a vezetőnek hogy hogy itt
úgy látom hogy itt nem működik és ami jó
és ez a személyes kapcsolat hogy néha
isten is
visszajelez akár nagyon erősen hogy hogy
fiú a kapcsolatot félretetted és megint
csak a menedzsment eszközökön
lovagolsz és ez különbözteti meg
szerintem minden más vezetőtől azt a azt
a keresztény vezetőt akinek van
integritása tehát egy ilyen keresztényen
keresztény egységként működik hogy hogy
folyamatos kapcsolata van az istennel és
és akkor eljutottunk oda hogy és ez a
kérdés akkor amit felteszek
hogy mit
jelent számodra az hogy hogy a
vállalkozást nem te vezetett hanem az
isten na ez ez ez ez ez egy nagyon
pontosan és mélyen megfogalmazott kérdés
úgyhogy ezt javaslom ezen közösen
gondolkozzunk
tovább először is azt emlelném ki hogy a
vállalkozásunkba tehát az exarlpsen
belül van egy vezetői testület tehát
hogy most vagyunk vagy heten benne ezt
egy körülbelül egy éve hoztam lét létre
ezt a vezetői testületet pontosan azzal
a szándékkal hogy bizonyos vezetői
terheket delegáljak tehát egy egy
testület legyen az aki konkrét
döntéseket hoz bizonyos kérdésekbe és ez
pont az tehát ebbe benne van egyrészt az
én limitációm hogy érzem azt hogy
limitált vagyok és hogyha azt akarom
hogy fejlődjön a szervezetünk akkor
muszáj bevonjak másokat is hogy ne az én
szintemen maradjon meg hanem nőjön túl
ez a szervezet rajtam és és
tehermentesítsen bizonyos szempontból de
benne van az is hogy úgy gondolom hogy
mások is képesek arra hogy döntsenek a
jó és a rossz között nem csak én megint
egy mély keresztény nelv hogy hogy nem
van egy zseniális vezető és akkor mögé
felsorakozik pár átlagember hanem van
egy átlagember aki aki úgy érzi hogy
vezetőnek van elhívva és átlagembereket
behív és együtt kezdenek el vezetni mert
együtt képesek vagyunk arra hogy hogy
döntést hozzunk és amúgy ilyen
szempontból az egész nyugati
világkeresztény tehát hogyha megnézzük a
a jogrendszerünket a jogrendszer k is
arra alapszik hogy az utolsó személynek
is van egy méltósága hiába hogy gyilkos
mégis meg megilleti őt a jog hogy
megvédjük amiatt mert van egy vele
született méltóság ami értékes és az a
vele született méltóság az onnan ered
hogy képes képes megjavulni képes arra
hogy hogy megtérjen hogy megbánja a
bűneit és egy produktív tagja legyen a
társadalomnak ez ez önmagában egy csoda
hogy egyáltalán létezik ez mert ez ez
nem magától érthető tehát 1000er évvel
ezelőtt kivégeztek egy tolvajt vagy
levágták a kezét manapság hiszünk abban
hogy eltévejedett és képes arra hogy
hogy megváltozzon és bár erre sokszor
van egy csomó ellenpélda hogy nem
változik valaki mégis intézményeket
hozunk létre mert esélyt akarunk adni az
embereknek akik akik eltévejedtek tehát
mélyen bennünk van ez a keresztény
gondolat és nem csak a cégünkbe hanem
nyilván a környezetünkben az egész
nyugati világnak a gondolatvilágában
benne van és lehetne teljesen másképp is
a világunk úgyhogy a az eredeti
kérdéshez visszatérve hogy hogy mit
jelent az hogy élő kapcsolatunk van
istennel az első az hogy nem csak nekem
van nem engem hívott el isten hogy
vezessem a céget hanem együtt egy ilyen
testülettel is valójában mindenkit a
cégen belül elhívott arra hogy figyeljen
és egy éber szenzorként vigyázzon arra
hogy a cégünk jó irányba menjen és és
bízom abban hogy ha több koponya
gondolkozik ugyanazon a problémán és
keresi a megoldást sokkal könnyebben
kapunk megoldást mintogyha én egyedül
gondolkoznék és akkor a a másik oldala
pedig ez az hogy nincs recept szerintem
ezért nem működnek a menedzsmenteszközök
mindenhol persze vannak nagyon jó
javaslatok
vannak
vannak tényleg olyan eszközök amiket
újra és újra be lehet vetni de
önmagukban ezek az eszközök nem képesek
arra hogy egy szervezetet összetartson
hanem ezek működnek és néha ilyen aut
automata pilóta üzemmódba tudják a
szervezetet működtetni ilyen vegetatív
üzemmódba de ahhoz hogy egy szervezet
fejlődjön ahhoz szükségünk van arra hogy
olyan dolgokba belenyúljunk amik
kaotikusak és még nincsenek benne a a
terveinkbe tehát olyan doméniumban
navigálni ahol ahol fogalmunk sincs hogy
mi fog történni belenyúlni egy új
üzletákba vagy egy projektet elvállalni
amiben még nincs tapasztalatunk vagy ha
bővül a cég önmagában
már a kultúrája egy kaotikus doméniumba
kerül ahol új territóriumra kerül
ahol nincsen recept akkor mi a mi a
válasz erre és a válasz az hogy
elkezdjük keresni a a a a kérdésekre a
válaszokat és a kérdés az hogy hogyan
keressük ezt a választ és van az a fajta
mód amikor mi idézőjelesen arrogáns
módon azt mondjuk hogy képesek vagyunk
magunktól választ adni a másik pedig az
hogy úgy gondoljuk hogy a bennünk levő
intuíció és a bennünk
levő csendes hang amelyik vezeti a a a
gondolatainkat az bölcsebb tud lenni
mint a az intellektusunk által
megfogalmazott döntések amiket hoznánk
és ez már gyakorlatilag ott van megint a
keresztény már a vallási határokat
súrolgatja ez ez erről szól ez egy élő
valami amikor alázatosan figyeljük hogy
hátha valami bölcsességet belénk
cseppent valami és akkor kérdés az hogy
ez mi mi ez az intuíció mi ez a a a a
belső csendes hang amit amit szokratész
is hallott amit
amit a keresztények szentléleknek
gondolnak és és más kultúrákban is
megjelenik de van valami ami amit nem
lehet leírni csak egyszerűen alázatosan
várni és hogyha kollektív ez ez nem
különbözik az imától nem különbözik
attól hogy
valaki követve ezt a csendes hangot azt
mondja hogy bármit is mond ez a csendes
hang az jobb mint amit én magamtól ki
tudok találni és a kérdés az hogy ez ez
ez működhet-e na ettől válik számomra a
kereszténység egzisztencialistává hogy
hogy ki kell próbálni nem lehet tudni a
választ erre de el kell indulni és ki
kell próbálni tehát számomra ettől válik
egy keresztény cég élő hitű
kereszténységgé hogy elkezdjük a
biznisvilágba is használni azokat az
elveket amelyeket amúgy a szentmisén
lehet hallani például vagy vagy a biblia
olvasásával vagy tanítások hallgatásával
és az hogy működhet-e ez praktikusan ezt
ezt úgy lehet meg tudni hogy elindulsz
elindulsz rálépsz a vízre ez újabb
keresztény
terminológia rálépünk a vízre és
megnézzük hogy mi lesz és bízunk abban
hogy a például az egyik amit mondott
jézus hogy hogy az igazság szabaddá tesz
bízunk abban hogy ha igazat mondunk
akkor tényleg az aminek a következménye
lesz annak amikor felszólalunk
annak annak a hatása sokkal szabadabbá
tesz és jobb lesz mint hogyha én
manipulatívan megválasztom a szavaimat
ez is hit kérdése miben hiszünk az
igazságban hiszünk vagy pedig a saját
manipulációnknak a saját
intellektusunkban hiszünk hogy képesek
vagyunk úgy alakítani a környezetünket
hogy az sokkal jobb legyen mint hogyha
az igazat mondtam volna és ezt nem
tudhatja az ember rálép és ez ez az
aktív rész amikor már nem lehet
menedsment
eszközökkel statikusan meghatározni a
cégünknek a menetét hanem ez egy
dinamikus újra és újra fellobbanó láng
ami ami ébenen tart és és és izgalmassá
teszi egy kalanddá teszi ezt az utat
igen nagyon sokszor hallottam a a hát
rengeteg vállalkozóval meg vezetővel
tartom a kapcsolatot és ők többük
közülük elmondja
hogy tehát így fogalmazott ugye az volt
a az volt az alapkérdés feléjük
hogy hogy őt hogyan őket hogyan látják
környezete és és néhányan így
fogalmazták meg ilyen nyersen hogy nem
tudom és nem is érdekel mert amíg a
lelki ismeretem tiszta és és arra a
vezetésre hallgatok amit amit úgy
gondolok hogy istentől jön addig a jó
úton vagyok
arogásnak tűnhet
mert hogy mi a garancia az arra hogy ez
tényleg működik viszont ugye stevenhen k
is mondja hogy ha elég sok ideig
csendben maradsz akkor meghallod a
lelkiismeretednek a hangját megszólal ez
a belső hang amiről beszéltél és amiről
mi hisszük hogy ez a szentlélek sugall
sugallata
intellektuálisan valóban
át átformáltuk gyakorlatilag a
világunkat
olyan narratívákat gyártottunk ami
nem hát de valószínűleg nem működik és
és mégis ezekben a narratívákban élünk
és ezért mondtam a legelején hogy ez egy
narratíva az amiben élünk és a
lelkiismeretünk az ami ami összekapcsol
az objektív valósággal és ha látnánk ezt
az objektív valóságot akkor ezt ezt én
úgy hívnám hogy ez az isten országa ühüm
és
és úgy gondolom hogy ez ez
a hogy mégsem annyira arogáns tehát az
amiről beszéltél az előbb hogy hogy
szabaddá tesz tehát hogy az a szabadság
hogy hogy én nem kell másnak megfeleljek
csak az istennek ez a ez az egyik
legnagyobb szabadság amit akár egy
vezető de akár egy ember el tud érni
emellett és ez most ilyen pejoratívan
hangzott hogy csak az istennek hiszen ő
állította a legmagasabb mércét mert azt
mondta hogy legyetek szentek na most ha
ezt a kettőt folyamatosan megcélozom és
erről beszéltünk sokat ez a fölfele
célozás akkor azt gondolom hogy hogy itt
itt csúcsosodik ki a keresztényvezetőnek
a a a jelleme a karaktere hogy hogy hogy
autonóm meg mert nem kell senki másnak
megfeleljen hanem istennek és és a
megszentelődés útján jár és ez ez nem
csak a a a vezetésében látszik hanem ez
akkor a családjában az életében és ez
nem csak a vezetőknek a feladata hanem
ez ez mindenkinek a feladata tehát hogy
hogy valahol mélyen ez a két dolog ami
ami szerintem
a keresztény vezetőt meghatározza és
akkor itt teljesen elfelejthetjük a
menedzsment eszközöket h itt egy nagyon
érdekes dolgot megpendítettél mégpedig
az hogy számomra egy nagy felismerés
volt hogy a szabadság addig volt egy
olyan képem a szab sságó a szabadság az
a teljes szabályoknak a a hiánya tehát
akkor vagyok szabad hogyha semminek nem
kell alávessem magam és ez a tökéletes
szabadság kábé az egyetemnek az első
félévéig gondoltam ezt amikor a a leg az
általam ismert legnagyobb szabadság eset
rám és és gyakorlatilag elköltözhettem
otthonról saját pénzügyeim voltak
úgymond kaptam elegendő pénzt hogy
megéljek egy hónapban és és
gyakorlatilag szétestem szétestem
darabokra amiatt mert mert nem volt mi
összetartsa nem volt belső fegyelmem és
a valójában amit most megfogalmaztál te
is az az hogy az igazi szabadság az
hogyha önként vállalva szolgálom istent
valójában a a a mózes amikor odamegy a
fáraóhoz és azt mondja hogy engedd el a
népem azért hogy és nem nem azért hogy
teljesen szabadok legyenek hanem azt
mondja engedd el a népemet engedd
szabadon a népemet azért hogy szolgálja
istent a pusztában és ez talán a
legnagyobb szabadságunk amikor amikor
szabadok leszünk arra hogy isten
országának az igazságai alapján
alakítsuk át az életünket talán ez a
legmagasabb szabadság
és és nem pedig a a szabályoknak a
hiánya ami viszont anarchiához vezet
vagy a szabadság vagyis a a a
szabályoknak az abszolút diktatúrája ami
a a ami azt is ismerjük valójában azt a
másik extrémumot is ismerjük tehát a két
extrémum közül az anarchia és a
diktatúra között a legnagyobb szabadság
az önként vállalt
alávetett az elveknek alávetett
élet ab egyet erről beszélgettünk és
igen a amit még megemlítettél ez a
számomra az egyik nagy felismerés az
volt hogy keresztény jelveket
vallani nem a gyengéknek az útja a és és
azért nem volt ez nyilvánvaló mert én
azt láttam hogy a katolikus egyház
vonzza azokat a személyeket akik akik
konfliktus kkerülőek akik akik hogy
legyen minden jó egy olyan környezetbe
tartozok ahol nem fogok kritikákat kapni
kereszténynek lenni egy konfliktus
kerülő kedves út ahol mindenki szeret
minket és számomra ez nem volt vonzó én
a kalandra vágytam arra vágytam hogy
hogy veszélyes környezetekbe a
határaimat súrolva tudjak élni és és
unalmas volt kereszténynek lenni mert
azt gondoltam a kereszténységreő hogy ez
a kereszténység de időközben jöttem rá
hogy hogy nem az hanem ez abszolút a
harcosoknak az útja ez abszolút a a a
bátrak útja és nem pedig a polyácáké és
erről kíváncsi lennék a véleményedre
hogy
hogyan hol látod ezt az erőt hogy
gyakorlatilag ezt mondtad hogy hogy nem
a kedves balfaszoknak a az útja a a a
kereszténység a bizniszvilágban hogy
látod hogyan működhet a kereszténység
hogyan működhet egy olyan működhet egy
nagy cél
kicsi cégnél látjuk hogy működik
működhet-e egy nagy cégnél például mi
történik akkor hogyha az vad kapitalista
környezetbe bekerül egy keresztény
valaki az
elveivel az a gondolat jutott eszembe
nem tudom hogy ki volt a
a kitől származik ez az idézet és csak
para parafrazálni tudom hogy hogy
először
hülyének néznek ez gandhi ez gandhi
akkor ezt ezt te valószínű jobban tudod
a gondolatot g de de mondd végig mond
végig hogy hogy először hülyének néznek
aztán harcolnak ellened aztán
győzöl röviden aztán nyersz és és azt
gondolom hogy hogy ez ez a ez a
keresztény út
és ezt ennek a lépéseit a
lábnyomait a legnagyobb szervezetben
amit hívjunk úgy hogy a föld lakosság a
társadalomban a a lábnyomokat ezeket
krisztus letette akit hülyének néztek
aztán harcoltak ellene aztán nyert és az
a nyereség az nem biztos hogy földi és
ez a másik amit a keresztény vezetőktől
tanultam akikkel beszélgettem hogy hogy
nem elsősorban a a bőség meg a boldogság
a
céljuk az egyik egyik
visszatérő motívum az az hogy valami
nyomot hagyni itt a földön de a másik az
hogy
hogy hogy elnyerni az örök
életet és ez ez ami
szintén egy megrendítő erejű és
szerintem egy egy nagy vadkapitalista
vagy korporatív világba is
hogy hogy látni olyan
embert aki
nem is ugyanabba a ligába játszik és
szerintem ez a a a keresztény vezető nem
ugyanabba a ligába játszik mert nem
ugyanazért a serlegért hajt
és hát nem is tudom hogy hogy lehet ezt
ezt jó hasonlattal megfogalmazni de
talán ez talán ez hogy hogy egy más egy
más úszómedencébe úszik egy más
más szabályok szerint működik
és és lehet hogy hogy a profit
maximalizálásban
ő alul
marad de amikor
integritásában megérkezik valahová az
élete végén akkor azt mondja hogy hogy a
nemes pályát azt azt megfutottam és a jó
harcot azt megharcoltam és és f és és
remélem hogy bemegyek isten örömébe és
innentől kezdve hogy egy egy teljesen
más pályát választ magának egy
keresztény vállalkozó vagy keresztény
vezető ez a szabadság és ez a nyugalom
ez megjön és ezt ezt nem annyira a helyi
vállalkozóktól hanem inkább a azok az
olvasmányaim a keresztényvezetési
elméletekből szűröm le
hogy hogy az a bónusz hogy életük van és
bőségben van itt a
földön de de nem ez a cél a keresztény
vezetőnek nem ez a célja
és nem tudom másképp kifejezni mint hogy
hogy ez egy más világ és ez tényleg egy
más világ egy láthatatlan világ na most
egyből feljöt ben nem egy cinikus hang
ezzel kapcsolatban hogy rendben rendben
a a az örök életet lehet megnyerem de a
számlát ki kell fizetni
szóval gondolkozhat-e valaki az örök
életről miközben
a piaci realitás ott van és és akkor
melyik a prioritás mármint nyilván hogy
most a az örök élet nagyobb prioritásnak
tűnik de de ha egy cég csődbe megy
akkor akkor mit kezd ezzel a
gondolatával szerintem hogyha elég
sokáig csendben vagyunk akkor megszólal
a
lelkiismeretünk és nekem azt mondja
hogy hogy mi a fontosabb a cég vagy az
ember és és akkor ott van a példabeszéd
a a gazdag ifjúval aki akinek azt mondja
jézus hogy oké követnél engem akkor add
el mindenedet és legyél földön futó ne
fizesd ki az utolsó
számládat de én vagyok a a nyeremény és
és túl egyszerűsítünk hogyha azt mondjuk
hogy minden a gazdasági
realitás szintjén dől el de akkor egyből
jöhet az a gondolat hogy jó akkor
egyáltalán miért akarunk keresztény
vezetés elméletről beszélni miért nem
foglalkozik a bizniszvilág a a biznis
dolgokkal és a a
keresztény tehát a vallás azokkal az
örök életbeli kérdésekkel amik fontosak
és tehát hogy hogy miért nem választjuk
a kettőt külön és akkor talán
visszaugrunk a pont egy órával ezelőtti
gondolathoz hogy ezeket nem lehet
elválasztani ühüm tehát nincs
nincs külön lélek nincs külön test a
kettő egymás nélkül nincs külön szellem
tehát ez a három ez a hármassága és én
beemelném negyediknek ugye a társadalmi
a a szociális kapcsolatokat de ez a ez a
három dimenzió ez egybe van az embernek
nem létezik és akkor most ez ilyen
furcsán fog hangz nem létezik
keresztényvezetés elmélet
csak úgy adja semmi be ugye az
absztraktba keresztény vezetők vannak
keresztény emberek akik vezetnek
keresztény emberek akik élik a biznis
tehát a gazdasági életben a gazdasági
világban az életüket és e ez nem kell
vezető lenni tehát hogy ugyanez a
szolgáló magatartás ugyanezek a a
keresztény értékek ezek ugyanúgy
kijönnek a gyártósor mellett is és
hallottam már ilyen történeteket és
beszélnek erről és a legtöbbet ugye egy
hát általunk ismert közös
mondjuk úgy hogy ilyen példaértékű cég a
baden bow houseenál lehet hallani ahol a
gyártósorok mellől mondják el az emberek
hogy milyen megrendítő hatása van annak
ahogy ők ők ott élnek egymás közt és és
a példamutatásukkal a bizonyságukkal
megvallják a hitüket tehát hogy nem nem
szétválasztható szerintem ez és nem is
ennyire éles a határ hogy akkor
most a spirititualitással foglalkozzon
az egyház és a a biznisz a gazdasággal
meg foglalkozzon a biznisz ühüm tehát
hogy hogy egységében integritásában
tekintsük az embert igen egyetértek ez
egy szép visszatérés volt és há talán
még azt tenném hozzá hogy amit amire
elég hamar rájöttem a az exarps
megalapításánál hogy ha nem lesz egy
olyan víziónk ami össze tudja tartani a
szervezetet csak idő kérdése hogy mikor
fognak nagyobb fizetést ajánlani egy
nagyobb cégnél amikor elég kompetensek
lesznek a a munkatársaim mikor fognak
elmenni egy
multihoz az egyetlen lehetőségem az hogy
valami olyan történetet találunk ki
közösen ami elég valóságos ahhoz hogy
feladjanak érte mindent ami szakmai
szempontból feladjanak mindent tehát
hogy hogy all in benne legyenek ebbe a
munkába és ez mélyebben ahhoz a
kérdéshez nyúlik vissza amit nietcsche
is mondott hogy az az értelmetlen
szenvedést az ember lelke nem tudja
elviselni tehát amikor amikor nincs
célunk az életben és csak úgy bolyongunk
egy akkor nem egy neutrális állapotban
vagyunk nem az van hogy ülünk az ágyunk
szélén és csak úgy vagyunk sem nem jó
kedvűek se nem rossz kedvűek hanem az
értelmetlen élet egy elviselhetetlen
szenvedés az életünkben céltalan
depresszív
öngyilkosságig sod sodorhat minket mert
az van hogy az az élet tragédiája erről
beszélgettünk most így kurtos arankával
az élet tragédiája a bőrünkigérr
mindenki megbetegszik mindenki meghal
körülöttünk és velünk együtt is és és az
évek ahogy telnek egy idő után keressük
a válaszokat hogy miért is csináljuk ezt
amit csinálunk és és és hogy hogyan
érdemes élni az életünket a legnagyobb
kérdés a miért és hogyha egy szervezet
nem tud a miértre válaszolni akkor azt
jelenti hogy csak bolyong tehát
emlékszem amikor a a annál a multinál
dolgoztam ahol a amit említettem most
nem akarom direkt a a a nevét
megemlíteni mert igazából nem tehet róla
tehát h ő egy olyan cég amelyik a profit
maximalizálásra hajlott emlékszem hogy
fiatalként nagyon-nagyon keményen
dolgoztam azért hogy hogy hogy hogy a
lehető legjobb munkát elvégezhessem amit
csak tudok tehát tényleg nagyon nagyon
nagyon figyeltem arra hogy kutatásokban
benne voltam a vgen belül a munkámat a
lehetőlegg gyorsabban elvégeztem és év
végén volt egy ilyen céges gyűlés és
ahol átvettük hogy hogy mi hogyan telt
az év és láttam hogy a romániai csapat
3%-kal növelte a profitot a fitness
szektorban és nagyon nagyon örvendett
mindenki én is igazából örvendtem neki
és amikor hazamentem akkor
elgondolkoztam azon hogy tényleg ezzel
telik el a fiatalságom hogy a fitness
szektorban 3% növelem egy amerikai
cégnek a
profitját ennek mi értelme van miért nem
csinálok mást miért pont ez csinálom meg
elegendő ez az életemnek elég célt ad
hogy hogy most növelem 3%-kal a profitot
és és a válasz az volt hogy nem
egyértelműen éreztem hogy valami nem jó
de az idő az telik és ahogy mondtam
folyamatosan ez az egzisztenciális
terror folyamatosan figyelmeztet minket
arra hogy meg fogunk halni és hogy hogy
csak idő kérdése az hogy hogy hogy
valami tragédia beüssön az életünkbe nem
beszélve arról hogy tehát a covid után
meg a háború után amit így élünk meg
mindenféle dolog tépi az életünket az ai
forradalom itt van folyamatosan változni
kell tanulni kell az ember elfárad az
ember elfárad és és azt látja hogy
mondjatok- jó okot hogy megéri élni
mondjatok-e jó okot hogy megéri
gyermeket vállalni erre a világra és
akkor itt jön be számomra a
kereszténység hogy ez már az a szint
ahol nem lehet felületes válaszokat adni
mert cinizmus vált ki az emberekben hogy
egy újabb ideológia egy
újabb felületes válasz ez nem fog minket
megtartani akkor amikor jönnek a a az
igazi hullámok
úgyhogy úgyhogy igen szóval visszatérve
a keresztény alapokhoz én azt látom hogy
ez amiatt nem a naívoknak és a
gyengéknek az útja és amiatt látom hogy
ez egy külön
kimagasló terület amin érdemes
gondolkozni hogy az igazi legmélyebb
kérdésekre ilyen szinten kapunk választ
tehát és megint visszatérve a
szientológiához pontosan itt próbál
betörni a szentológia hogy válaszokat
próbál adni a miértre olyan válaszokat
hogy miért miért szenved a a mi miért
szenveesz te mint cégvezető miért vagy
te elfáradva miért miért tapasztalod azt
hogy az emberekben nem lehet megbízni
hogy mindent te csinálsz és el vagy
fáradva és és amikor elfordulsz akkor az
emberek kitolnak veled ezekre a
miértekre mi a válasz és és van erre egy
keresztény válasz is a keresztény válasz
az hogy minden
ember keresi az értelmét hogy miért él
és kell keresne mint cégvezető egy olyan
miértet amire rá tudja tenni az életét
valaki ami hiteles ami nem
egy nem egy manipulatív mondat hogy jól
hangzik és csináljuk ezt azért hogy hogy
hogy valójában a profitot maximalizáljuk
hanem őszintén amikor mindenki a szívére
teszi a kezét akkor azt mondja hogy igen
ez a legmélyebb dolog amit meg tudok
fogalmazni mert visszatérve az nietsi
gondolatra a céltalan ember tehát a a az
értelmetlen szenvedést az ember nem
tudja elviselni viszont az értelmes
szenvedést igen mi az értelmes szenvedés
az hogyha egy célnak alárendelem de mi a
cél és akkor ez a kérdés mi a cél és a
válasz erre az hogy nem tudjuk de minél
magasabb célt tudunk kitűzni annál
értelmesebbé válik az életünk úgyhogy
keressük együtt azt hogy mitől válik egy
cél a lehetőlegérrtelmes ebé na és ez az
a ez az a pont ahol már mindig minden
specifikus tehát minden egyes szervezet
saját magának kell erre választ adjon
hogy mi a cél miért létezik ez a pékség
miért létezik ez a fogorvosi rendelő
miért létezik ez a a az iskola miért
létezik ez a a civil szervezet mert a
miért ad választ és a miért az ami
összeköt minket és ez ez az a válasz ami
elviselhetővé teszi hogyha megkapjuk a
megfelelő miértet és őszintén
alárendelünk mindent egyszeren
megoldódik minden olyan kérdés hogy
például a fluktuáció hogy ott hagyják az
emberek a munkahelyüket és lecsökken
mert mert az emberek legtöbbször azért
hagyják ott mert a vezető hiteltelen
céltalan amit csinálnak nem kielégítő
szakmailag a a nem elég nagy kihívás
viszont hogyha ezeket mind integrálni
tudjuk azt mondjuk hogy oké itt a vízió
ennek rendelünk mindent alá akkor simán
az emberek azt mondják hogy oké lehet
hogy szakmailag nem fejlődök de most
azért dolgozunk hogy és akkor itt jön a
miértre a válasz üüm és egy szinte még
visszbb is léphetünk a szervezeti
szintről az egyéni szintre hiszen
ugye coocachsként is dolgozom és azt
látom
hogy hogy az emberek ből kiölte a
társadalom ezt az igényt hogy
megfogalmazzák a miértjüket vagy
egyszerűen célt fogalmazzanak meg
maguknak sodródnak nagyon sok ember
sodródik és a legjobb miért az az amit
meg tud erre a kérdésre választ adni az
az hogy az amiről beszéltünk ez ez az
egzisztenciális dolog hogy hát ne
halljak éhen vagy tudjam kifizetni a
következő
számlámat és de de nagyon sokan nem is
gondolkoznak ezen nem gondolkoznak a
miérten és
és paradigmaváltó hatása van amikor azon
kezdünk beszélgetni személyes
beszélgetésben valakivel hogy hogy hogy
mi a
víziód és és hová akarsz eljutni hová
szeretnél eljutni az életed végére mi az
a mi az a dolog amit hogy h ha felírsz a
hűtőszekrényedre és te reggel fölkelsz
akkor akkor ez elönt adrenalinnal és azt
mondod hogy na ez az a dolog amiért én
ma reggel fölkeltem és el akarok indulni
munkába és és ez a dolog amiért
egyáltalán érdemes fölkelni
és hogyha van valakinek egy ilyen célja
és ez a cél ez változhat idővel de
hogyha most ki tud egy ilyen
célt dolgozni magából azt hiszem hogy ez
ennek már nagyon nagy ereje van
és
hogyha ez a cél
az örök
élet ez ez meg hát ennek meg világot
felforgató hatása van és emellé befér
még egy csomó minden befér a szolgálat
befél a befér a a bőség is befér befér
minden
oda akarok kilyukadni
hogy ki lehet találni akáre gegy
vállalkozásnak a miértjét ki lehet
találni akár a személyes miértedet és
erre erre szintén vannak
módszertanok de
mennyivel mondjam azt hogy keresztényib
megkérdezni
hiszen hiszem azt hogy hogy van egy
egy mag amit elültetett az isten
belénk vagy van valamilyen akarata az
életünkre nézve
és és itt megint dimenzióbeli különbség
van aközött hogy hogy én kitalálom
magamat és meghatározok egy célt
vagy vagy
kikutatom hogy mi a terve istennek velem
és itt megint egy
hát nem tudom egy ilyen igen egy
dimenzióváltás vagy egy egy
szintlépés dimenzióváltás ilyen
szempontból egy nagyon jó
metafor mer a szintlépés olyan mint
hogyha ha ugyanabból a lépcsőfokból még
egyet megtennénk de a dimenzióváltás ez
ez gyakorlatilag a két dimenzióból a
három dimenzióba való lépés és az a az a
szépebbe hogy eljön az a pont amikor a
felületes válaszok nem elegendőek tehát
akkor muszáj a legmélyebb kérdést
feltenni és akkor akkor ha tehát nekem
mindig problémám volt azzal a fajta
motivációs eszközökkel hogy a tükörbe
belenézel és elmondod azt hogy szép vagy
vagy a tükörbe belenézel és azt mondod
hogy ma sikeres leszek és akkor bevonzom
magamnak a pozitív dolgokat nem
mintogyha nem hinnék a szavaknak a
teremtő erejében hanem az hogy ez
felületes annyira felületes annyira
jelentéktelen ez amikor amikor
céltalanul bolyongsz az életbe és nem
kapod az utadat akkor hiába mondod
ezeket egyszerűen nincs kedved felkelni
az a beleütköző a tárgyakban mert nem
láthad fizikailag a a teret magad körül
minden összeszűkü minden í ízetlenné és
szintntelenné válik na akkor gyere
mindenféle ilyen felületes vonatokkal és
gyakorlatilag ez a ez a kérdés itt hogy
meg tudom-e fogalmazni mi a legmagasabb
cél számomra mert ha tényleg őszintén
meg tudom fogalmazni az tényleg
felfordít mint világ felforgató hatása
van ahogy
mondtad itt egy gondolatot még
hozzáfűznék mert mert az ember
gondolkozik ezen és és óriási
intellektuális erő veszítés az hogy ezen
akkor gondolkozzál amikor amikor béke
van és nyugalom mert
hány tragédia után halljuk ezt a kérdést
hogy
miért és és akkor már csak visszamenőleg
lehet narratívákat gyártani a múltunkra
de ezen lehet dolgozni hogy mi az én
miértem hogy hogy ne ne csak a a a
vállalkozásom csődbe meni és akkor
kérdezzem meg hogy mi ennek a célja az
életemben vagy mert most már csak eszköz
lett
hanem előtte mondjuk úgy hogy
megtervezni
jó attól lehet hogy csődbe megy a
vállalkozásod vagy az enyém vagy bárkié
de de akkor már nem a a a kétségbe esett
miértek vannak hanem az hogy hogy önként
vállalt követ a következő önként vállat
szenvedés következik és megyünk előre
mert istennek az akaratába járok attól
még lehet hogy megbukott egy vállalkozás
mert nem voltam felkészülve rossz
iparákba választottam satöbbi
ühüm
ugyanúgy nem csak vállalkozás szinten
lehet
rossz irányba menni és az egy fokos
korrigáció az nem mindig segít
m van amikor amikor annyira elmegyünk
hogy hogy padlót kell fogni és újra
felállni és és gyakorlatilag a megtérés
történet ezek ezek erről szólnak
hogy hogy van aki úgy tapasztalja meg
istennek a jelenlétét az az életébe hogy
egyszer padlót fog és akkor onnan áll
föl és azt mondja hogy mostantól tök jól
vagyok van akinek működik a ez az egy
fokos korrigáció mondjuk úgy hogy a
megszentelődés útján így így szépen
beáll a radarja az
egyenesbe végezetül mert most most már
lassan letelik az időnk így ahogy nézem
az órát az lenne a kérdésem hogy mit
mondanál azoknak akik azt mondják ezn
nagyon jól hangzik igazából az az
igazság hogy jól hangzik és én remélem
hogy igazatok is van hogy hogy a
keresztény vezetés működik hol tudok
nekifogni hol hol hol tudok ezekről
olvasni ez az egyik kérdésem és akkor
így szeretném hogyha külön kitérni
magáról a coaching személetről és arról
a
coaching tapasztalatról ami eddig
felgyűlt mi az amit te is csinálsz és
hogy mi miben különbözik ez a coaching
szemlélet magától most egy fel egy
képzéstől ami részt vesz ühüm jó hát
akkor a kérdésre az elejétől vál
válaszolnék
hogy hol lehet elkezdeni a keresztény
vezetést hogy kell elkezdeni igen hol
lehet most anyagokat kapni hol lehet
elkezdeni mit lehet ezzel kapcsolatban
most igen az első
lépés
szerintem a legnehezebb magadra zárni a
hálószobádat letérdelni az ágy mellé és
azt mondani hogy uram itt
vagyok és én ezen az úton el akarok
indulni és innentől kezdve a többi az
meg meg
menedzsment van menedzsment igazából és
akkor ezért mondtam hogy akkor menjünk
tovább de örülök hogy ezt mondtad mert
én nem ezt mondtam volna de mostr most
már én is ezt mondaná de ez az első hogy
hogy akkor meghozni ezt a döntést és és
ez egy ez egy életre szóló valami ez egy
ez egy megtérés és lehet radikálisan
megtérni és mindent de én ezt úgy
szoktam mondani hogy hogy van amikor az
embernek megtérik megtér egyszer az
intellektusa aztán aztán megtér a
pénztárcája és akkor aztán aztán lassan
megtér a vállalkozása is és akkor így
így lassanként
isten felé fordítja az összes antennáját
és és ez ez hogy hogy én letérdelek a az
ágy mellé vagy a keresztlábához és azt
mondom hogy uram elfogadom azt a
megváltó munkát amit te értem tettél és
a kezedbe adom ezt a vállalkozást és én
keresztény ként akarom vezetni ezt a
vállalkozást és akkor utána beírom a
google-be hogy keresztény vezetői
könyvek de tudok mondani párat akik az
életemben nagyon meghatározóak voltak ez
john maxwell craig grosell
simon syek patrick lencioni és mindenki
más oldalával
foglalkozik ennek az egésznek tehát hogy
lehet könyveket olvasni lehet tudást
tudásbázist építeni de úgyis vízrelépés
lesz a az első ilyen próbálkozás és
lehet ezt buktácsolva rosszul csinálni
mert mert minden nap ugyanabba a
hálószobába ugyanannál a z ágynál tud
befejeződni és akkor holnap újra és újra
és újra
és és a tudás bázis az így nő és a a
coaching az hát gyakorlatilag ez az edző
ez arról szól hogy hogy van
amikor nehéz a sok információból a
tudásbázisból gyakorlatot vagy mondjuk
úgy hogy gyakorlati lépéseket
megtenni főleg azért mert erről már
beszéltél az előbb hogy hogy nincs meg
az a belső fegyelem és hogyha nincs ő
fegyelem akkor kell egy külső és és a
coach például ebben tud segíteni hogy
egy coaching ülésen megbeszéljük hogy
hogy akkor mi az a következő lépés amit
megszeretnél tenni és én megkérdezem
hogy
megtetted-e
vagy vagy felhívlak hogy akkor most tedd
megüüm eljött a reggel ma bemész a
céghez mit tudsz
csinálni gyakorlatilag
ezt a modellt nagyon szeretem levezetni
a a coachinggal
hogy a coaching az ott van félúton a
kontempláció az elmélkedés és a másiknak
a menedzselése között
minél inkább a kontempláció fel megyünk
annál kevesebb az emberi behatás minél
inkább a más menedzselése felé megyünk
annál nagyobb a segítő szándék és a
segítő behatás
is az ed ő most ha nem is a sportra
értjük de a coóach az nem
csinálja jobban mint
te hanem abban tud segíteni hogy te
jobban csináld és ezt a példát ezt
mondtam hogy a yamaikai
edzőcsapatnak a cs a az edzője vagyis a
futócsapatnak a rövidtá futócsapatnak az
edzője egy zseniális figura körülbelül
130 kgó-s szerintem gyerekkoráb futott
utoljára és még is egy olyan sikeres
csapatot tud felépíteni akik az olimpiai
rövidtáfutást szinte minden számban
viszik
és hogy mi a
a a harmadik az hogy hogy a coachingban
is létezik a következő dimenzió a
függőleges dimenzió az
hogy nem
csak jó ötleteket beszélünk meg nem csak
oskodás van hanem az a az a típusú hogy
mondjam az
a vágy bennem hogy én szeretném hogyha
isten vezetne ebben a dologban és és
elhiszem azt hogy hogy hárman megyünk
egy coaching folyamatban a kliens isten
és én tehát akkor egy ilyen
coaching tapasztalatot úgy írnál le hogy
ott van a konkrét személy me hgatod a és
együtt átbeszélitek a problémákat és
javasolsz neki elveket és együtt
keresitek az útját hogy hogyan lehet ezt
praktikusan alkalmazni az ő esetében és
te ott vagy folyamatosan időnként
találkoztok ez heti rendszerességes igen
heti rendszerességgel vagy két hetente
találkozunk és azt mondanám hogy még még
bár eddig se megyünk el hogy javasolok
neki
elveket mert van időnk
megvárni amíg ezek az elvek megszületnek
benne vagy vagyis előjönnek igazából és
ez a ez a gondolat viszi az egészet
előre hogy ha elég sokáig csendben
vagyunk akkor a lelkiismeretünk
megszólal ühüm és és bizonyos
elakadásoknál sokszor már hamarabb szól
a lelkiismeretünk hogy ezen hogyan kéne
tovább menni kell az a bátorítás hogy
akkor most belépek abba a liftbe üüm
ez sosem egy
lökés hogy a lztes példával tehát nem
egy hátbarúgás de már megvan az a
gondolat a legtöbb esetben hogy hogy
merre mennék tovább
megvan a tudása a kliensnek róla de
nincs meg a bátorsága nincs meg az a
fegyelme esetleg ami ebbe az irányba
tovább
vinné ső mi mi mi történik egy olyan
esetben mit mondanál annak a személynek
aki azt mondja hogy nekem nincs időm
nincs időm arra hogy tehát nekem a
problémám most égető és sürgős és én ezt
a csendes kontemplációs folyamatot ha
szimpatikus lehet egy másik életben meg
tudnám csinálni de ebbe a pörgős világba
amikor nap mint nap meg kell felelni a
piaci realitásoknak ak ezt ezt
egyszerűen lehetetlen kivitelezni lehet
hogy hetente tudnék időt szakítani sőt
biztos vagyok benne de nincs még két
évem arra hogy elérjek arra a
bölcsességi szintre hogy tegyük fel
megfordítsam a céget két
két gondolat van az egyik az
radikálisabb és ezt
ezt most nemrég hallottam egy egy
magyarországi coachs ismerősömtől aki
azt mondta hogy dolgozz intenzíven és
pihensz majd az intenzíven
a ez ez egy ilyen durvább hogy hogy
kinek mire van ideje
a másik meg az hogy nagyon sokszor
javaslom a klienseknek azt hogy ha
valamire nincs idejük
akkor helyettesítsék azt és akár egy
egyszerű találkozásnál
ha valaki mit tudom kér tőlük egy
találkozót helyettesítse a konkrétan
kimondva a nincs időmet arra hogy nem
fontos és amikor mélyen magadba nézel és
azt talál meghívsz engem kávézni és és
mondhatom tényleg hogy nincs
időm de a valóság az hogy nem annyira
fontos hogy én most elmenjek veled
kávézni és amikor saját magamra azt
mondom hogy hogy a saját életem nem elég
fontos ahhoz hogy időm legyen a saját
növekedésemre fejlődésemre az megint egy
ilyen megrázó dolog hogy könnyű az időre
fogni
hogy bizonyos dolgokra nincs időm de
igazából a a prioritások felállítása az
elsődleges szempont és ha bárki hallgató
megpróbálja majd az életében azt hogy
hogy egy bizonyos
szituációban azt mondja valamire hogy
azt mondaná hogy nincs időm rá és
helyettesíti arra hogy ez nem
fontos akkor akkor eldől hogy az fontos
vagy nem fontos könnyű azt mondani hogy
nincs időm lerázni
bárkit vagy bármilyen fejlődést
növekedést
akár de amikor azt mondom hogy nem
fontos akkor lehet hogy tényleg
megnyugszom és azt mondom hogy ez
valóban nem fontos és akkor nyugodtan
mondhatok rá
nemet de az is lehet hogy megszólal a
lelkiismeretem és azt mondja hogy de ez
baromi fontos ez csak egy álca hogy
nincs időm és ez azért van és ez egy
szerintem záró gondolat mert a legtöbb
ember összetéveszti az értékét az
eredményességével és azt gondolja hogy
én csak akkor vagyok értékes hogyha
eredményes vagyok holott
ez nem igaz ez egy
hazugság mert isten szemében mindannyian
értékesek vagyunk és anyánk méhétől
fogva értékesnek teremtett meg minket és
az értékü k
az az megint egy más dimenzión van mint
az eredményességünk lehet hogy nem lesz
csak 1%-os
profitnövekedés de az értékemet nem az
eredményeim határozzák
meg ez zárógondolatnak tökéletes volt
köszönöm szépen isti elfogadtod a
meghívást és köszönjük szépen a kedves
hallgatóknak hogy végigallgattátok ezt
kérlek írjátok meg majd kommentbe hogy
mi a véleményetek rengeteg provokatív
gondolat megfogalmazódott az elmúlt
időszak én nagyon kíváncsi vagyok hogy
ilyen nyíltan a keresztényvezetés
elméletről most beszélek podcastben
először és és tényleg érdekel hogy mi a
véleményetek ezzel
kapcsolatban köszönöm még egyszer hogy
itt voltál és és egy szép napot szi ha
tetszett ez a műsor akkor iratkozz fel
kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket köszönjük a vckker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az ötvös
udvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöett volna ez létre